JEFFREY BAIER: When I
first saw Khan Academy,
what was attractive
to me was the ability
for students to learn concepts
at their own pace, when
they were ready for them.
And it brings that learning to
students both in the classroom
and at home with a seamless
transition from one location
to the next.
ALYSSA GALLAGHER:
What caught our eye
in using it to
differentiate instruction
is the interface that
the students have,
and really on the back end,
all of the complex data
that's provided to the teachers.
It would take them hours to
get that same kind of data.
SANDRA McGONAGLE: It
was easy to roll out.
Thankfully, I have some teachers
who are just great risk takers
and saw the potential of how
it would help their students.
Cost wise is great.
I know there are other math
programs out there that you
can purchase, but it is a
cost and it's not real time.
JEFFREY BAIER: The data sets
the Khan Academy provides
allows principals at
the school site level
to have conversations
with their teachers about
progress students are making;
to recognize very quickly which
students are grasping
skills and moving ahead,
which students are struggling
with a particular concept,
and which students
are stuck and need
some additional intervention.
ALYSSA GALLAGHER: Khan
Academy is directly
helping because every
day, every child
has the opportunity
to have individualized
learning opportunities, where
they are specifically working
at their level, being provided
with instantaneous feedback.
Which is not something
that they would
get in the traditional
teacher lecture model.
SANDRA McGONAGLE:
I see every student
utterly engaged in
what they're doing.
And they are talking about math.
They are excited about math.
They're appropriately
challenged.
And those kids who are
really math superstars
are able to push themselves
to where they want to be.
JEFFREY BAIER: The
parent involvement aspect
is important, as well,
because they can actually
see the teaching, the
instruction, as the student
hears the instruction in class,
as well, because they, too,
can watch the videos.
It brings an opportunity
into the home for parents
to have conversations
with their children
about math, about
learning, and about what
they're doing in school.
SANDRA McGONAGLE: I am most
excited that our kids are
happy and excited about
learning, and especially
learning math, because it
seems to be the older you get
in grades, you either have
determined for yourself
that you love math, or
you're not good at math.
And so if kids can have
success at their level,
to build that mental
math capability,
I think that's amazing.
JEFFREY BAIER: When both
teachers and students
are excited about the
teaching and learning going on
in the classroom, it has
limitless possibilities.